the patriots now
six and seven
peter and by all appearances
not headed for the postseason they had a
tough road anyway steve kornacki had
their number uh chance at 21 on sunday
night and i i thought well they probably
got a better chance than that not after
last night they don't i think it's over
i think even if they win their last
three which with the bills and the
dolphins on the horizon is no gimme i
think even then nine and seven is not
going to be good enough it's just weird
to see and to say that the patriots
who've been to the playoffs every year
since 2008 who've had at least 10 wins
every year since 2003
are done
yeah and i think last night
showed so many things
as painful as they are that the patriots
needed to see
and on that long plane trip east you
know that four and a half hour plane
trip to
uh back to new england i think one of
the things that other than maybe getting
some sleep other some of the things that
that bill belichick and his staff
really have to think about i mean in no
particular order but i'll give you three
of them
number one you know obviously the
biggest thing is what are you gonna do
with the quarterback situation headed
into next year are you just going to let
uh
you know let
everything play out and then do pick up
sticks in june the way you did this year
or are you actually gonna have a plan
and go after a guy now that your cap
is in a better situation number two what
are you gonna do with all these guys who
opted out and want to come back and who
you have to pay real money to if they do
come back i'm looking at you dante
hightower i mean what are the patriots
going to do with all of those
players who they who they probably are
going to have to make decisions on and i
think the third thing mike is
just the understanding that as great as
bill belichick the coach has been
bill belichick the general manager
deserves as much criticism as jerry
jones has gotten in recent years because
bill belichick the general manager has
not put his roster in good position
particularly with the offensive skill
players
uh that he knew he had to do
in the off season and and and look when
you don't get what i would call a
franchise receiver
when you're drafting two guys who've
made zero impact to be your tight ends
of the future
uh in the in the third round you know
there's something problem there there's
there's some problem there there's
something that might be a little
systemic
and if i were belichick i would want to
examine
everything about my personnel
acquisition
style and substance
that has shown this roster to be so far
behind the offensive eight ball in the
nfl right now
and there's got to be a fascinating
story behind this story because nick
casario the vp of player personnel
setting the table for belichick is
belichick ignoring the advice of casario
relying too heavily on it is there a
strong enough balance
to belichick as he has amassed more
power and influence and fame and rings
to the point where he can pick whoever
he wants and no one will say boo because
he's such a good coach and of course
it's not like anyone from the patriots
is ever going to open up and tell us all
these things but there there is reason
to believe that that there are some
intriguing answers behind that that
thick curtain that the patriots
routinely put up the the curtain uh is
is dropping on cam newton's time with
the patriots here's the quarterback from
last night regarding his struggles and
also bill belichick on who his
quarterback is going forward
you know we just got to be better and it
starts with me personally
uh just have to make more plays are you
concerned about being benched for next
week or anything like that
um
that's not my call i'm just doing what
i'm asked that's about to still go into
each and every week but the mentality to
keep getting better and that's what i
plan on doing you're gonna stick with
cam next week at quarterback great
question mike i really pledge as our
quarterback what has cam showed you to
to stick by him so much
he's our quarterback he could just
answer that one
you know the jerk routine isn't nearly
as appealing when you're six and seven
bill
i i'm yeah and i called him out for
being that way when you know when they
were 12-0 it's just i i don't get it
it's a fair question it's a legitimate
question
when you bench your starter with
significant time left in the game the
question of who your quarterback is next
week is a fair and appropriate question
peter
no question about it and
look i i would say
you know
this is this is probably i i'm sure it's
a need your thing but
if we had a if if our lightning round
today or or at some point were to say
okay mike quick name the five most
disappointing players in football this
year
and if if i told you that cam newton was
going to be pretty much healthy now he's
obviously got some uh
core muscle issue now or you know he's
got some some pain in his torso
somewhere
you know
but
cam newton's been one of the most
disappointing players in football the
amazing thing is
think about this mike
he has started 12 football games
with josh mcdaniels as his offensive
coordinator
he had five touchdown passes
back in the glory days of cam you know
i'm sure i'd have to look it up but i'm
sure he threw five touchdowns in a game
at some point in his life
and that to me
is absolutely startling those are those
aren't even steve grogan numbers
you know those aren't those aren't tom
hodgson numbers
and and to me i just think it is it is
startling you know how cam's game
basically has fallen off the edge of a
cliff
he did throw five touchdown passes
against washington at one point you are
correct tied a franchise record with
five touchdown passes you are correct
sir
so you are correct sir so yes it is it
is stunning and look he was
looking good before he got coveted 19
missed some time when he came back there
were questions about whether or not he
had any type of lingering brain fog he
didn't appreciate the question what was
posed to him by greg hill of weei but
then later cam said yeah it took me a
while to get right again and
we've seen this twice now where he's
been benched for jared stidham you
really have to wonder who the
quarterback is going to be in 2021 i
posted that question last night on
twitter and i think within a couple of
minutes had 200 suggestions some of
which were legitimate some of which were
sarcastic but who will the quarterback
of the new england patriots be in 2021
because i get the feeling it's not going
to be cam newton and in the flashes
we've seen of jared stidham i haven't
seen enough to make me think he's going
to be the guy either peter
i can't imagine that they would go to
camp giving stidhum the job i mean i
think
if if i'm predicting in the way we
we talked about this mike in the spring
and uh
i said and i said it
many times
bill belichick's way
is not to set the market on march 15th
it just isn't or to make his decision on
march 15th his way is to say
let's see people go out and spend the
stupid money and then i'll be laying in
the weeds and i'll get the next best
option that's exactly what they did in
waiting for june and waiting for cam
newton and it seemed like a brilliant
idea at the time
and but now right now when you look at
this situation
you may have to be the new england
patriots and say
is this the year we maybe over pick a
quarterback over pick say a zach wilson
of brigham young in the first round and
you know it or
do you go out and do you try to make a
pre-emptive strike
and try to get
say a matthew stafford for a two and a
four or something like that so those are
the kind of things that to me
i would be investigating as soon as the
season is over because i don't see any
logical way that you bring back a guy
who in his last three starts
in none of his last three starts has
thrown for 120 yards this is like you
know that's what you look at when you
look at football in 1937
not when you look at football
we now have more than 1200 suggestions
in response to the question that you may
have seen on the screen a few minutes
ago and when i popped on it just now the
first name that came up was andrew luck
that is an intriguing rabbit hole down
which to venture if that were to happen
i don't think andrew luck who made a
quick appearance this week to tout
jacoby brissette for the walter payton
man of the year i don't think that's
going to happen but you know i've i i've
i've been fascinated by
this kind of idol chatter that has
absolutely no merit to it and will never
happen
but it is fun
to at least wonder about
a potential return of the prodigal son
back to boston now tom brady just said
yesterday after being in tampa in
december you won't catch me dead living
in the northeast again so that makes it
even less likely but man
look to the extent that we're keeping
score
on
who did better in the first year post
breakup even though the buccaneers and
tom brady aren't as good as it looked
like they were going to be
they're at least headed for the
postseason so i guess that's brady one
belichick zero at least for now
yeah mike i uh
you know of all the things that might
happen this offseason
i'd put that in the
98th
poll
uh you know both because you think bill
belichick's bill belichick is going to
admit that uh he's got to go groveling
back to tom brady do you think tom brady
who told me in the off season hey peter
this is the first year
in 30 years of football that i've ever
had an offensive coach with a big grin
you know
it's
this is uh it's a funny
it's fun to think about
but it's not going to happen
they really do have an issue and as you
said one option is to draft a
quarterback earlier than maybe your
draft position would suggest another
option is to try to trade up but what
trade assets do you even have how much
of your future do you want to mortgage
to try to move higher up in the draft
and look at this point
with the patriots playoff chances
far lower than 21 percent we'll get the
updated numbers from kornacki on
football night in america on sunday
night
there is the question of whether you
just put stiderm or brian hoyer out
there and all your other backups in
order to evaluate young players and let
nature take its course and if you're
gonna not make the playoffs you may as
well be six and ten and draft higher
that's the dirty little secret that the
nfl never wants us to focus on but at
this point there's nothing to be gained
by finishing nine and seven if you're
not going to make the playoffs unless
you want to be able to say we've had a
non-losing season every year since 2000
or some ego massaging factoid like that
you're better off if you're thinking
about drafting a quarterback being
higher in the stack than lower peter
you realize of course that if they
finish nine and seven
they might
do extreme damage to the new york jets
getting uh
getting there getting trevor lawrence to
be their quarterback
so
look there's all sorts of little
nefarious scenarios you can think of
i don't think bill belichick is going to
have any of any of them i think he's
just going to try to win every one of
these games
and then just let nature take its course
after that wherever they're drafting
he's gonna draft and if he needs to
spend i think i think i think this the
first time he might seriously consider
taking essentially his 2022 number one
uh which could be a good number one
again too could be a middle of the round
or
13th pick or whatever
but
if he could package that along with this
year's pick who knows maybe he can move
up to number three or number four and he
gets in position to take one of the uh
one of the primo quarterbacks this year
you know i had a fleeting vision there
january three
patriots hosting the jets jets leading
uh oh no jets trailing late i screwed up
my vision jets trailing late
and then on the last play of the game
the patriots uses zero blitz and the
jets get there
[Laughter]
and the jaguars get trevor lawrence not
the new york jets
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports